Water.
You might not see it,
but this is...
Here's why.
Every molecule of water on the Earth
and inside you
or any other living thing
has existed for billions of years.
After it came to Earth,
that water has been cycling
through rocks, air, animals,
plants and back again.
Each molecule has been
on an incredible voyage
before coming to you.
At some point, the water inside you
would have been inside dinosaurs,
bacteria, the oceans, storm clouds,
the polar ice caps and much more.
All of the water on Earth is alien.
They might be a familiar
part of our world,
but our oceans formed
hundreds of millions of years
after our planet took shape.
The water arrived on asteroids
and comets from space,
objects from the edge
of our solar system.
They were leftovers of the
vast clouds of dust and rocks
that didn't quite
make it into planets.
This is the origin of all the water
you can see on the Earth.
Water doesn't follow the
normal rules of chemistry.
For a start, it shouldn't really
be a liquid on our planet.
A water molecule is made
from two very light atoms,
hydrogen and oxygen.
And at the temperatures and pressures
on the surface of the Earth,
rules of chemistry say that
water should be a gas.
And, unlike any other chemical,
when water freezes it expands.
And so ice floats on water.
Now you see this every day,
but take a moment to think
about how weird that is.
Over time, this odd behaviour
has been very useful.
By insulating the water underneath,
floating ice has enabled complex life
to survive and evolve on our planet,
despite the many ice ages that have
frozen the Earth's surface solid.
And the strangeness
just goes on and on.
Did you know that hot water
freezes faster than cold?
Yes, really.
No-one knows why.
Water molecules can float upwards,
against the force of gravity.
That's because they love
to stick to each other.
They're so good at it
that they can actually pull each
other up through tiny channels,
such as the tiny blood vessels
in your body.
That's how oxygen and nutrients
reach the edges of your brain.
The same process,
called capillary action,
allows plants to move water
from deep below the ground
to nourish the leaves and branches
that grow in the sunshine.
Our solar system
is drowning in water.
Once upon a time,
we thought that we were alone
on Earth with so much water,
but in fact it's the second most
common molecule in the universe.
We now know there's water
on the moon, on Mars, Pluto.
In fact there's H2O on almost
every object in our solar system.
And where there's water,
there could be life.
So pour yourself
a glass of water now,
and take a good look at this
colourless, featureless
and tasteless material.
It's actually remarkable.
It breaks so many rules of chemistry
that scientists struggle
to understand it.
But without its rebel behaviour,
none of us, nor our world,
would exist.
You're only here watching this video
because water is so strange.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)